[Musique]
alors les conférences ted sont bien
souvent l'occasion d'entendre de très
beau message d'espoir en ce qui me
concerne je viens tenter plutôt
aujourd'hui de vous désespérez je ne
veux pas vous désespérez totalement
j'imagine qu'un désespoir total conduite
au suicide ce que je ne souhaite
évidemment à personne ici je veux plus
précisément tenter de vous enlever un
espoir l'espoir que notre civilisation
puisse durer encore longtemps
un espoir qui s'exprime par exemple dans
cette notion omniprésente aujourd'hui de
développement durable ou dans celle plus
récente de croissance verte
pourquoi vouloir vous ôter cet espoir
avoue qu'être six jeunes pleins
d'enthousiasmé de belles idées d'énergie
positive parce que c'est je crois
l'une des conditions pour que nous
évitions peut-être je dis bien peut-être
une terrible catastrophe
je m'explique depuis plus de 50 ans
maintenant des travaux de recherche
s'accumulent pour souligner une
contradiction fondamentale de notre
civilisation
nous vivons dans un monde fini
ressources limitées et pourtant nous
visons une croissance économique infinie
une croissance illimitée fait l'univers
est immense peut-être même un fini mais
pour le moment au moins
l'espèce humaine n'a pas d'autre endroit
que la planète terre ou se reproduire
nous habitons donc bel et bien un espace
fini un espace dans lequel même nos
ressources dites renouvelables ne le
sont que jusqu'à un certain point une
espèce vivante trop malmené fini par
disparaître
pourtant nous prétendons pouvoir
produire dans cet espace relativement
clos toujours plus de biens et de
services
en un mot toujours plus de marchandises
dans la mesure où cette production
implique nécessairement la consommation
de ressources terrestres et la
production de déchets elle ne peut pas
croître indéfiniment pour avoir une
croissance économique durable ou
soutenable il faudrait que son impact
écologique se stabilise et même décline
ce qui n'est pas du tout ce que nous
observons actuellement en dépit des
discours rassurants sur les effets
bénéfiques d'une dématérialisation
progressive de nos économies il ya
plusieurs raisons à cela tout d'abord
l'économie de services n'a pas remplacé
l'économie industrielle elle s'est
ajoutée aux activités industrielles qui
pour une grande part ont été délocalisés
à l'échelle planétaire l'impact
écologique de notre économie de nos
économies s'est donc accru par ailleurs
d' économie dite du savoir ou de
l'information n'est pas si immatériel
qu'on veut bien
croire ou le dire sur le plan
énergétique en particulier nos petites
machines informatiques et des
infrastructures qui permettent leur
visage sont très gourmandes un iphone
consomme en moyenne autant d'électricité
qu'un réfrigérateur standard plus
simplement encore des marchandises
immatériel cela n'existe pas même pour
vendre un service il faut un minimum au
minimum un humain qu'il convient de
nourrir d'habiller de loger de
transporter etc etc
on peut donc très difficilement vouloir
produire toujours plus de marchandises
sans accroître toujours plus notre
impact écologique
bien sûr il est possible d'accomplir
certains progrès dans l'utilisation de
ressources terrestres
mais ces progrès sont limitées notamment
par un phénomène que l'on appelle
l'effet rebond il a été inspiré il a été
repéré par non il n'y a plus d'un siècle
par l'économiste stanley jones qui avait
remarqué que les gains d'efficacité des
machines à vapeur ne se traduisait pas
par une baisse de la consommation de
charbon mais au contraire par une hausse
de cette consommation
pour quelles raisons mais parce que le
charbon devenait aussi toujours tout
ainsi toujours plus rentable à utiliser
dans une société productiviste tout
moyen d'économiser une ressource va en
fait souvent en stimuler la consommation
on peut aussi bien sûr mettre en place
des incitations pour réduire cette
consommation ou réduire la production de
déchets suivant le principe de
l'utilisateur-payeur ou du pollueur
payeur
mais ces dispositifs s'ils ne sont pas
simplement symbolique vont en fait
imposer généralement un ralentissement
des activités économiques concernés ils
ont donc toutes les chances de faire
l'objet de vives oppositions comme l'a
montré par exemple la révolte des
bonnets rouges contre l'écotaxe en
france à l'automne dernier dans des
sociétés qui dépendent de la croissance
économique toute mesure qui menace de
ralentir celle ci risque d'être rejeté
par le plus grand nombre
on en revient donc à cette contradiction
fondamentale il y a des limites
physiques et biologiques à notre
capacité à produire toujours plus de
marchandises mais en même temps nos
sociétés repose sur la quête de
croissance et nous agissons donc comme
si ses limites n'existait pas dans ces
conditions le moment va arriver
fatalement ou soit par manque de
ressources soit par trop plein de
déchets c'est formidable machine à
produire des marchandises que sont les
entreprises ne vont plus pouvoir tourner
nos économies vont alors s'effondrer et
une grande partie des 7 8 9 ou 10
milliards d'êtres humains qui peupleront
la planète vont tout simplement
disparaître pour le dire de manière
imagée lorsque le garde manger ce vide
que la poubelle envahi la cuisine il
faut s'attendre à ce que le gâteau que
l'on y prépare ne puisse plus nourrir
toute la maisonnée
mais qu'en plus ils empoisonnent ceux
qui le moins
quand est-ce que cet effondrement de nos
économies risque-t-il de se produire
sans doute bien plus vite qu'on ne le
pense la croissance économique en effet
même à un taux peu élevés suit une
progression exponentielle c'est-à-dire
qu'elle accélère constamment pour
illustrer cet effet d'accélération on
peut évoquer d'exemple classique du
nénuphar dont la surface double double
chaque jour et à qui il faut 30 jours
pour recouvrir les temps sur lequel ils
poussent au début sa progression est
lente à peine perceptible d'une journée
à l'autre
le 28ème jour encore seul un quart de
l'étang est recouvert de nénuphars mais
2 30e jour c'est terminé deux jours ont
suffi pour que les trois-quarts de
l'étang soit en veille la croissance de
nos économies ne double pas chaque année
elle n'en reste pas moins exponentielle
2% par an le volume des marchandises
produites va doubler non pas en 50 ans
mais en trente cinq ans du coup son
impact écologique tend également à
suivre une telle progression
on est aux prises ici avec ce que l'on
appelle les phénomènes de rétroaction
positive
les spécialistes des systèmes désigne
par ce terme des effets d'un processus
qui ont tendance à renforcer ce
processus
autrement dit la conséquence d'un
phénomène devient elle même l'une des
causes de celui ci un bel exemple si
j'ose dire et celui de certains effets
du réchauffement climatique
ce réchauffement fait fondre
actuellement les neiges et des glaces
qui réfléchissent les rayons du soleil
et contribuer de la sorte
refroidissement terrestre la disparition
de ces neiges et de ses glaces va donc
augmenter encore le réchauffement de
l'atmosphère autres rétroaction positive
du même genre la fonte du pergélisol qui
retient prisonnier d'énormes quantités
de méthane un gaz à effet de serre dont
la libération dans l'atmosphère devrait
agraver rapidement le phénomène du
réchauffement global
en somme notre situation sur le plan
écologique risque de se dégrader si non
d'un seul coup en tout cas d'une manière
soudaine
ne nous laissons plus guère de temps
alors pour réagir en outre certains
dégâts seront devenu irréversible
on ne reculera pas d'un coup de baguette
magique les espèces animales qui sont en
voie d'extinction aujourd'hui cette
thèse de l'effondrement de plus en plus
admise parce qu'ils tentent
d'appréhender ces questions dans leur
globalité
elle n'est pas nouvelle cependant cela
fait plus de quarante ans qu'elle est
défendue entre autres par l'équipe de
dennis meadows cette équipe de
chercheurs travaillant en haïti à
l'origine a tenté au début des années
1970 de modéliser les interactions entre
l'espèce humaine et la planète terre en
se servant la théorie des systèmes et de
l'informatique
leur objectif n'était pas temps de
prédire l'avenir que de comprendre la
dynamique du système global dans lequel
nous et vous
les différents scénarios générés par
leurs modèles aboutissent tous la même
conclusion
sauf si nous stoppons la croissance
économique à l'échelle mondiale notre
civilisation se condamne à
d'effondrement et cela probablement
avant la fin du 21e siècle
car nous sommes d'ores et déjà en
situation de dépassement des limites
écologiques de notre planète dans le cas
du scénario standard celui dans lequel
rien n'est fait pour corriger des
problèmes causés par la croissance
économique
l'effondrement des buts même avant 2050
or si l'on observe ce qui s'est
réellement passé depuis que ce scénario
était à l'aube élaboré on constate que
sur le plan économique démographiques et
écologiques les choses se sont déroulées
d'une manière très semblables aux
projections de ce scénario qui était
aussi baptisé business as usual
c'est d'autant plus préoccupant que les
efforts qu'il faudrait accomplir pour
tenter de stabiliser la situation sont
désormais bien plus considérable qu'il
ne l'était au début des années 70 nous
avons perdu un temps précieux qui sera
difficile de rattraper pour l'équipe
meadows qu'elle actualisé récemment son
étude initiale nous avons toutefois
encore le choix un choix très restreint
cependant entre d'un côté une
décroissance forcé subie qui s'imposera
spontanément et de manière
catastrophique d'ici quelques décennies
à peine et d'un autre côté une
décroissance volontaire assumer
contrôler autant que possible et lancé
sans plus attendre cette deuxième option
c'est d'une décroissance choisie repose
sur l'espoir d'une sortie en douceur de
notre modèle de civilisation
une sortie pas trop désastreuse pour
l'espèce humaine bien sûr à cet espoir
on peut opposer celui d'une série
d'innovations technologiques majeures
qui résoudrait le problème de la fin du
pétrole ou celui des gaz à effet de
serre par exemple et permettrait ainsi
de poursuivre la croissance en éloignant
le risque d'effondrement
une telle éventualité est très peu
probable mais n'est pas impossible
est ce raisonnable de faire de paris
qu'elle advienne je ne crois pas
toutefois l'avenir reste inconnaissable
et on ne peut empêcher personne de se
raccrocher à un tel espoir aussi peu
fondée soit il cela dit il ya d'autres
bonnes raisons de vouloir en finir avec
la course à la production de
marchandises dans laquelle nous sommes
embarqués à l'échelle planétaire et
c'est celle que je voudrais évoquer à
présent dans la seconde partie de mon
exposé tout d'abord il faut prendre
conscience que cette fameuse croissance
ne constitue plus un facteur de
bien-être dans les sociétés les plus
riches
elle semble l'être encore dans les
sociétés les plus pauvres mais plus dans
les nôtres au delà d'un certain niveau
de pib par habitant
la corrélation disparaît en effet entre
croissance économique
bien-être que celui ci soit appréhendé à
partir des indicateurs subjectifs comme
le sentiment de bonheur ou d'indicateurs
objectifs tels que le niveau de
scolarisation ou encore l'espérance de
vie
dans le cas du sentiment de bien-être au
quotidien il n'y a plus de corrélation
avec le pib dans les pays où celui ci
dépasse environ 15 mille dollars annuels
par habitant
dans le cas du niveau d'éducation ce
seuil se situe autour de douze mille
dollars annuels par habitant
dans le cas de l'espérance de vie ce
seuil est environ à 18 milles dollars
pour mémoire au québec nous sommes bien
au delà de ces seuils puisque le pib par
habitant il dépasse les 30 mille dollars
annuels si l'on ajoute à cette
décorrélation entre pib et bien-être
le fait que la croissance économique ne
génère plus forcément d'emplois dans nos
sociétés à quoi bon pour suivre cette
course à la production de marchandises
pourquoi en faire un impératif absolu
comme le font nos dirigeants politiques
et économiques
à qui profite vraiment cette croissance
sinon une toute petite frange de la
population de nos pays
si l'on souhaite véritablement augmenter
le bien être du plus grand nombre il
semble qu'une solution prometteuse se
trouve du côté d'une réduction des
inégalités au sein de nos sociétés
sur ce point je vous renvoie en
particulier aux travaux de richard
wilkinson et au livre qu'il a publié
avec kate pickett sur le sujet wilkinson
a offert également au moins une
conférence ted
vous y apprendrez entre autres choses
intéressantes en matière d'espérance de
vie
mieux vous par exemple être un pauvre
suédois car riche anglais l'égalité des
conditions profite à tout le monde alors
que l'inégalité affecte même le
bien-être des mieux nantis
telle est la thèse centrale de wilkinson
qu'il faut vraiment qu'il vaut vraiment
la peine de découvrir une chose est
certaine la croissance économique a
cessé d'être un facteur de mieux-être
pour les humains actuels au moins en
occident
si l'on considère en outre que la
poursuite de cette croissance menace
l'avenir de l'humanité
on dispose donc à présent de deux bonnes
raisons de refuser cette course à la
production de marchandises mais on peut
aller plus loin cesser de courir
collectivement après l'augmentation de
notre pib pourrait également s'avérer
libérateur pour la plupart d'entre nous
cette course est très dure en effet y
compris pour ceux qui en occupe la tête
elle repose sur une concurrence
généralisée entre nous tous le nous
désignons à présent de l'humanité
entière ou presque
le sociologue max weber en parlait comme
d'une cage d'acier il décrivait ainsi
chacun trouve aujourd'hui en naissant
l'économie capitaliste établi comme un
immense cosmos un habitacle dans lequel
il doit vivre et auquel ne peut rien
changer
du moins en tant qu'individu dans la
mesure où l'individu est impliqué dans
les rapports de l'économie de marché il
est contraint à se conformer aux règles
d'action capitalisme le fabricant qui
agiraient continuellement à l'encontre
de ces règles serait éliminé de la scène
économique tout aussi infailliblement
que seraient jetés à la rue
l'ouvrier qui ne pourraient ne
voudraient s'y adapter fin de citation
autrement dit chacun doit trouver le
moyen de contribuer directement ou
indirectement à la production de
marchandises sous peine de rester sur le
bord du chemin
quiconque n'y parvient pas non seulement
perd toute autonomie sur le plan
matériel mais se retrouve également sans
identité sans identité positive en tout
cas d' où l' angoisse et de désespoir de
ceux qui sont sans emploi
d'où aussi la peur le stress l'anxiété
qui éprouvent ceux qui ont la chance
d'en avoir et qui craignent de le perdre
d'où le surinvestissement dans le
travail pour garder sa place ou essayer
d'en gagner quelques unes
d'où la sueur composent surconsommation
pardon de toutes sortes de substances
reconnues ou non par le corps médical
pour thune pour tenter de tenir le coup
d'où les épidémies d'épuisement
professionnel de dépression qui frappe
un grand nombre d'entre nous mais cette
course n'est pas seulement épuisante
elle a aussi quelque chose de
profondément insensé y compris sur le
plan individuel
l'écrivain bukowski exprime avec sa rage
coutumières au moins une partie du
problème
je cite comment diable un être humain
peut-il se réjouir de se faire réveiller
à 6h30 du matin par une alarme sauté du
lit s'habiller se forcer à avaler
quelque chose chier pisser se brosser
les dents et les cheveux puis affronter
des embouteillages pour aller faire
gagner un paquet de fric à quelqu'un qui
s'étend en plus à ce qu'on lui en soit
reconnaissants nous ne sommes pas tous
là certes il reste que nous avons appris
à trouver normal de soumettre nos
aspirations les plus profondes aux
règles d'action capitaliste comme
dimitri beurre c'est ainsi que bon
nombre des plus grandes décisions de nos
existences sont prises en considérant
d'abord la question combien cela va-t-il
me rapporter me coûtait plutôt que la
question
ce choix va t'il me permettre de me
réaliser pleinement de m'accomplir et de
m'épanouir en tant qu'être humain pour
en avoir souvent parlé avec je sais que
beaucoup d'étudiants de cette école ont
choisi de s'y inscrire non pas par goût
pour la gestion mais avant tout dans
l'espoir de s'assurer une place pas trop
inconfortable dans cette course à la
production de marchandises
ce faisant ils ont renoncé à des projets
plus personnels
ils ont renoncé en sommes à être même ce
n'est pas les critiquer que de le
souligner cette contrainte s'impose à
tout le monde y compris à ceux qui comme
vous et moi dispose d'une marge de
liberté bien plus considérables que
celles de la plupart des êtres humains
aujourd'hui faire objection de
croissance et donc aussi tenté de
s'évader de cette cage d'acier dont nous
sommes prisonniers de sortir de cette
roue infernale dans laquelle nous
tournons sans fin comme des haltères ce
ne sera certes pas facile
l'une des choses qui nous retiennent
dans cette cage ce sont des marchandises
qui s'y accumulent merveilleuse et
fascinante marchandises comment résister
à leur pouvoir d'attraction
il est évidemment bien plus facile
d'aller à l'épicerie du coin chercher
une pizza surgelée offertes à un prix
dérisoire que de fabriquer soi même
cette pizza la cage d'acier a quelque
chose d'un pays de cocagne où les
poulets rôtis vous tombe tout cuit dans
le bec mais c'est un piège un terrible
piège plus nous y venons à nos besoins à
l'aide de marchandises plus celle ci se
rendre indispensable - nous devenons
capables de nous en passer
plus les entreprises qui les produisent
deviennent alors nécessaire et puissante
plus se renforce en définitive la course
à la croissance et ses règles du jeu
contraignant bref acheter une pizza
surgelée à 3 dollars à l'épicerie du
point coûte en réalité très cher
puisqu'il en va de notre autonomie et de
notre liberté la plus essentielle
vous en doutez penser à cette
marchandise particulièrement séduisant
et l'automobile nous avons aujourd'hui
la liberté d'en acquérir une assez
facilement nous avons le choix entre de
nombreux modèles et de multiples marques
en revanche il ya une liberté dont nous
ne disposons plus c'est celle de vivre
sans voiture même ceux qui comme moi
n'ont pas dépendre étroitement dans leur
quotidien de l'automobile si les
voitures de la région montréalaise ne
peuvent plus rouler demain ce sera le
chaos absolu pour tout le monde même
pour moi comme dit le philosophe oui
marion acheter une voiture ce n'est pas
acheter seulement un moyen de
déplacement s'est acheté une
civilisation avec la bagnole vient toute
une armada la route le parking les
bétonneuses les diverses pollutions la
défiguration du paysage et les
catastrophes industrielles comme celle
de lac mégantic
sans compter les morts et les airs les
des accidentés de la route à ces
contraintes lourdes sur le plan
collectif
s'ajoute le temps passe et
individuellement gagné l'argent
nécessaire pour utiliser cette machine
et le temps perdu dans des
embouteillages causés par ces mêmes
machines
bref vu sous cet angle la voiture n'a
rien de cet instrument de liberté
que les publicitaires continuent de nous
faire miroiter et ce qui vaut pour cette
marchandise emblématique vaut pour
toutes les autres elton au bout du
compte la réduire bien plus notre
autonomie que notre labeur voilà
pourquoi il est essentiel de résister à
leur charme ensorceleur voilà aussi
pourquoi il faut rompre résolument avec
cette course à la production de
marchandises dans laquelle nous sommes
entraînés au total et en résumé refuser
la croissance économique s'impose pour
au moins trois raisons essentielles
parce qu elle est destructrice sur le
plan écologique parce qu'elle n'améliore
plus le sort de la majeure partie
d'entre nous et enfin parce qu'elle est
aliénante
c'est à dire qu'elle nous empêche
d'exercer notre liberté et de rester
maître de nous mêmes il me semble que ce
sont là des raisons amplement suffisante
pour comme je le disais au des poireaux
départ cessé d'entretenir l'espoir que
notre civilisation fondée sur la
croissance perdure encore longtemps et
plus vite nous apprendrons que nous
abandonnerons cet espoir plus nos
chances d'éviter le pire augmenteront
reste une série d'objections j'en
évoquerez 3 rapidement la première la
plus évidente une décroissance
volontaire à échelle planétaire est elle
vraiment envisageable
n'est ce pas un projet totalement
utopique il est grand temps je crois de
renverser l'accusent l'accusation
l'utopie aujourd'hui c'est de continuer
à penser qu'une croissance économique
infinie soit possible dans un monde fini
les rêveurs ou les affabulateurs sont
ceux qui entretiennent cet espoir mais
deuxième objection la croissance n'était
elle pas dans la nature de l'homme celui
ci ne cherche-t-il pas toujours à
améliorer sa condition il n'entretient
pas alors nécessairement concurrence
avec ses semblables puisque les
ressources terrestres sont limitées il
suffit de faire un peu d'histoire
d'anthropologie d'éthologie pour
réaliser que l'homme n'est pas forcément
un loup pour l'homme qui n'est pas
toujours cet animal égoïste cherchant à
maximiser son utilité que nous présente
la théorie économique standard
si beaucoup d'êtres humains semblent
agir aujourd'hui conformément aux
prédictions de cette théorie
c'est la conséquence de la course à la
croissance qui leur est imposée et non
pas sa cause non seulement nous sommes
capables de coopérer entre humains mais
nous en avons profondément besoin en ce
sens en ce sens nos sociétés qui nous
placent en situation de concurrence
permanente les uns contre les autres
options sont proprement inhumaine c'est
pourquoi il faut réinventer les balles
troisième et dernière objection mais
avez vous un plan un programme un modèle
au moins d'une part je ne crois pas
qu'il soit possible de planifier
l'innovation radicale
il ya là une contradiction fondamentale
dans les termes
d'autre part il y à un grand danger à
vouloir mettre en oeuvre un plan
prédéfini qui vaudrait pour tout le
monde et en tous lieux pour ne pas
accoucher du pire
l'invention de sociétés post croissante
en croissance doit être rigoureusement
démocratique
cela suppose d'abord qu'une majorité
d'entre nous soient convaincus de la
nécessité d'en finir avec la course à la
croissance
je suis venu cet après-midi pour vous
demander de contribuer à former cette
majorité
merci
[Applaudissements]